- My intentions with this project
were not malicious at all.
I really was curious and
wanted to expose the weaknesses
so that we can can
collectively, as a community,
get better at developing
products like this.
(energetic music)
I'm Leanne Luce, and the editor
and found of The Fashion Robot.
On my blog, I write about
different technologies
that are being used in
the fashion industry.
I think a lot of people
think of wrist wearables
when they think of wearable tech.
Fitness trackers and heart
monitors and things like that.
Wearables can be a lot
of different things.
So, I recently saw that
Tommy Hilfiger's Tommy brand
launched a line of smart garments
that would award you
points for wearing them.
The product by Tommy Hilfiger
is a garment with a smart tag.
And the smart tag is part of the game,
kind of like Pokemon GO.
There are two major ways to
win points through this app,
one of them is by getting
active wear points,
which just means that the chip itself
is moving around during the day.
And the second way is to go to
these locations and get points.
With the points, you can win rewards.
One of their awards is to go
to the Tommy Hilfiger fashion show.
Other rewards are as simple
as 15% off your next purchase.
What was interesting about it
is that it's so easy to hack.
(suspenseful music)
I'm gonna show you two ways
to hack this collection.
The first one is hardware based.
So, we picked up one of the
Tommy Hilfiger t-shirts.
With the smart tag, it had a number
of weaknesses that I wanted to expose.
One of them is that you can remove it
really easily from the garment.
So, for me, that meant that
I could wear it anywhere.
And I didn't need to carry
around any of Tommy's garments.
I could just take the chip with me,
and still gain points through the app.
The second one is by
hacking the phone itself,
and spoofing your location.
It's crazy simple to fake your location.
Basically, I downloaded a app
that would spoof my location on my phone.
You just drop a pin on a map
pretending where you are.
And then, on the phone, you just watch
the little arrow moving around the map
to the place that you
just told it you were.
Here we have the iPhone 6
with Tommy Jeans XPLORE
downloaded onto it.
I can see the map, and I can see
where it wants me to go
to receive these points.
So, I can go ahead and drop my pin there,
clip Move here, click XPLORE,
and I just received points for that visit.
When I started, I was at the
bottom of the leader board.
Okay, I just looked at the app,
and it looks like I have 689
in the last like two days of
actively hacking this app.
It has put me in fifth place
in Tommy Hilfiger's leaderboard.
(suspenseful music)
I decided I was going to make
a necklace to hold the chip
so that I wouldn't have
to think about it so much.
You can basically double
your points every day
by having active wear points.
So, I made a necklace
to hold the chip itself.
Basically, I just put it right in here.
I close this, and voila.
I could just passively be
gaining active wear points
without ever thinking about it.
And there we go.
(lighthearted music)
I was pretty surprised by how quickly
I was able to climb up the leaderboard.
There was a woman who had
like over 1,000 points,
and she was at number one.
And I didn't really think it was
gonna be that easy to get there.
(lighthearted music)
But in the matter of a few days,
I saw myself leap from fifth
to fourth to third to first.
And that happened pretty quickly.
Holy cow, I am number
one on the leaderboard.
That is so cool.
So, after thinking about
this a little bit I decided
that I was getting into a moral
gray area with hacking this device.
The thing that scared me
about this was it's a game,
but in this game, there
are monetary rewards,
or rewards that can be exchanged
for something of monetary value.
So, I'm going to stop now
that I've reached the
top of the leaderboard.
You know, I had no intention of redeeming
any of these points for
any kind of rewards.
It's not about that at all.
My intention for this video series
is really not about breaking
the law, or being malicious.
It's really just to raise awareness.
I wish I had a better
answer to the question,
how could this thing be better?
Because I do think that that's kind of
the million dollar question right now.
Right now is this really exciting moment
where there's so much
exploration in technology
and data science and wearables.
And that's a really cool thing.
(lighthearted music)
- [Man] Hey, guys, we're--
- [All] Pero Like.
- Do you know it's
Hispanic Heritage Month?
(speaks Spanish)
- For more Latino content.
- Subscribe here.